yeah welcome to the splits video and
dumb haha pre move against the Kings
gambit all right yeah this guy is just
moving instantly dumb down might see
five probably take here yeah at least
I've got the F file open typical feature
from the Kings gambit I'm not sure that
I want to play D 32 g for early because
he then gets the knight to e form hmm
okay Gabby prevents d3 d4 ok well let's
player in the most direct fashion my
opponents do that all the time without
thinking too much and it's mostly
working so on I try to do the same so
I'm see for the hour cannot really take
so let's play see form so i gained um
bit of space on the queenside and
still on the FR dictates that I do
something on the kingside so try to get
an ID on you for okay if it takes on b5
i'll take the end now Knight to c4 it's
also not a bad square yea rather
complicated term and unusual position
yeah I don't think I'm them kind of from
stereotypic play with Queenie 1g3 um
gives me anything probably need to play
on the queenside yeah the instant a five
also I'm what's interesting no question
surprising the squid caption ok but you
probably didn't want to allow a six
the idea tech b5 very M unusual position
as mentioned already some to some people
is so is an issue and probably need to
do that yeah but see six this week no no
doubt about it yeah I couldn't couldn't
turn kappa the spawn dumb quite um
disappointing the cell development like
just as a pawn up don't really have much
to show for it I mean not much as a yeah
it's so far too friendly I'm just a gone
down I'm not sure that Queen a six is
really great but but it keeps the palm
at least so
yeah I need to activate the bishop it's
it's really a bad piece on YouTube yeah
this is helpful I mean maybe I get the
Bishop to c4 this really what to improve
my position considerably yeah it's much
better on b3 then only two yeah I must I
must keep it simple yeah now i can get a
porn back do I want to probably I want
and so may be the only opportunity to
really get it back night give form I
control c5 so cannot pin and Bishop g5
from you should be five I thought rook
e1 but maybe we should be too then it's
a bit hairy but okay I needed to get I
needed to get this this back 96 right c6
maybe this was too ambitious of course I
could have taken enter it's so not much
happening yeah he's got the Bishop g5
but somehow doesn't want to play it
Quincy I but I've got Roxy form
must be cautious not kicking not King to
into our III of course now maybe have
some chances to learn to win this beep
on so possible yeah now I got this pawn
down to 37 seconds though first control
the second-ranked I'll make sure that I
get to get some temple now let's let's
play actively this is better and now the
ideas d 5 or let's say I'm play with the
pawns rookie 7 rook is success also i'm
good idea
nice some this can easily get a meeting
net e6 we go ahead and how what does he
do now look ahead is checkmate yeah he
was he had a great position of course um
probably around here black at some is
probably a close to winning i mean it's
its opponent and good pieces yeah it's
very good for black this however was
very helpful activating my bishop and
after this i call so can't play Bishop
c4 the worst is over here because my
bishop is really really strong and c4
and it's not so clear how he converts
converts the extra part here maybe rupee
bonus better well no but ok this is this
isn't clear at all Bishop g5 is strong
here I'm pretty sure about that a te
didn't take this chance and play down
played passively
still Bishop g5 here it did their up
later smooth dan TM I was getting
getting a material maybe you look maybe
a maybe night b3 is even better here
oops so I'm check quickly of course this
was the move I feared but this is not
really strong 96 m cannot he cannot keep
the e6 porn okay we're in the game it
also was very good for white and at the
end there was what's this meeting
meeting idea and this is checkmate no
way to prevent yeah okay I managed even
with 11 seconds on the clock while the
Kings gambit didn't really need to good
good opening position okay thanks for
watching